marvel has put out a spider-man miles
morales
launch trailer excited to watch this
guys
i'm so conflicted on what i should do so
the ps5 comes out november 12th
and of course i want to get a ps5 and
i'm going to get a ps5
but i really want to play this game
right away i've
really messed up on not ordering in
advance the ps5 online
i might have to to struggle at a store
to try to get well shank
somebody yeah it just sounds like a
really uncomfortable experience after
what last week was like
i want to get it comfortably but i also
want to play this game right away so i'm
like should i just get it on ps4 and
then just
play it as soon as possible or should i
just be a little patient
get it later with the ps5 that sounds
like the one i wanted when is patience
ever paid but i'm in such a rush
all right let's watch this get it on
both
oh ps5
i don't know if i'm ready to fly solo
you gotta take the oath
i promise to do everything in my power
to protect this city
i promise
don't trust anybody
[Music]
oh
[Music]
you're spiderman
[Music]
are you feeling it are you feeling it
people
are you feeling the nipple
[Music]
my
chills
i've made a decision i'm gonna wait
spider cat that's what we all i'm gonna
get a ps5 anyway i gotta just wait i
gotta switch
i just gotta wait it's gonna be that
much better anticipation is underrated
in the age of binging and on demand
i know i'm a contributor to that oh my
god that looks so good
it looks so beautiful if i'm gonna get a
ps5 anyway i might as well just wait a
little bit
and then i'll review it really late when
you guys have already moved on to
another game
man loving the way the prowler looks in
this trailer it looks really badass
he has more of a another prowler
being more direct villain and he kind of
seems like he's
anti-hero something like that or yeah
yeah somewhere in the gray at least
where he's
you know able to have a conversation
with miles still
he looks like he's fighting the good
fight at times or maybe he learns who
miles is and he's like god at odds
between himself
man but that's my nephew what do i do
you know yeah i can't i can't keep on
doing the wrong
thing when i yeah i'm gonna inevitably
run into my family member in the streets
and have to fight him at some point
he might be more of a father figure to
miles in this game
because miles is dead spoilers
spoilers miles's dad he passed away
in the first game there there's themes
here that feel you know
obviously just the most morales story
that of course when you think about
spider-verse of
him having spider-man powers trying to
come into his own and not just compare
himself to the spider-man before him and
really just make a name for himself and
embrace the identity that he
is spider-man now i love that kind of
that kind of dichotomy that he's dealing
with but i imagine it could be a little
bit even more complex for his
relationship with aaron davis because
his father did pass away maybe aaron
davis is actually more of the father
figure for him this time around this
felt like a movie trailer in a lot of
ways because i was getting caught up in
like oh man like the story of this game
looks really engaging and i want to see
where that goes and i want to you know
see how like the working dynamic with
genki leaves exactly
like yeah this made me really want to
jump in and like walk around in the
world and yeah do spider-man stuff and
go fight the rhino and all sorts of
other things
yeah this just looks so appealing and
and again like i think there's something
magical lately happening around
spider-man especially spider-man
spider-man
where it's like really unlocking both
the imagination but also the emotion
that can be found in these stories and
like to be excited about that
in a video game context is like kind of
special to me i'm also excited for the
soundtracks man that sounds great
sounds awesome and it's always risky
with youtube
it always makes these a fun like
guessing game will they let us keep it
they're not all right guys well
spider-man miles morales did you already
pre-order it leave your thoughts down
below hey why don't you subscribe and
click that notification bell keep a
lookout for any more coverage we do of
it or when my review is up
i'll see what guest i can get if juan
doesn't play
i would love to play maybe ps5 will be
my time last
jump back here but not least
flav doran flev my man been getting to
know you a little bit better as a late
from the uk mid-20s
sexy and he also has been contemplating
whether or not
he wants to start up his own type of
movie talk youtube channel of sorts you
can feel a little bit nervous from time
to time but phleb
i'm telling you man we've talked plenty
you really know your movies you know how
to give some good analysis and great
opinions
i heavily encourage you to just take the
step man experiment
try stuff out you seem like you already
have such great observation skills
put it to the test i feel like you got a
chance give it a shot and if you fail
you fail and then you just hate yourself
and blame me
yeah and then you know you let your life
spiral off into ruin and uh
it's our fault entirely but i don't
think that'll be the case
no i have faith in you flavorful flev
that's your channel name